well hello and welcome to our
2010 online meeting live on bs
today is thursday 14th
october
to start announcing us i call on
sonia to join me on the podium for
an announcement on the european year of
youth
sonia
at  leaked
president's announcement melting ice in her
state of the union address the
commission is today adopting its
official proposal to make
2022 the european year of youth
this year we will correct all the  young people
to become active citizens and
agents of positive change it
will also support
their personal, social and
professional development city possibilities
offered by the policies of the
european union in collaboration
with other institutions of the
european union the member states the
civil society organizations
and young people themselves the commission will
organize a number of activities
throughout the year and will consider
of a new initiative
the views of young people shared
at the conference on the future
of europe will also shape the
actions and events
during the year the commission
also publishes today its latest
report on the  youth which gives an
overview of the situation of people in Europe
in terms of education,
training, employment and
civic and political participation
for more information
please see our
press release thank you
mode sonia nlyte woodside johannes faut
one week to august 9th innovation in
entrepreneur outfit
your in nice
six titles hi media nurun to find nobel prize
energy technology
of
mercy many johannes
regarding today's meeting
please note that the executive vice president
despite tv star and the
commissioner thierry breton party if this
morning at the informal video conference
of telecommunications
ministers the ministers will discuss the
proposed
artificial intelligence legislation
this is a key part of
european union policy to
promote the development
and adoption of artificial intelligence
while addressing the potential risks
that some of these systems  can
present for security and fundamental rights
the Breton commissioner will take part in the
press conference following
this meeting scheduled around 2.30 p.m.
please reserve your questions on
this subject
for him.
questions and I'll pass the floor on
interactions to odile
today
yes hello at home I would like a
few practical details
about the climate conference
glasgow I note that the committee of the
regions insists a lot on
a rolls of cities and regions in
the implementation of the green deal and they
have already published their
representatives at this conference and I
would like to know  See how it works
with the representatives of the
European Parliament of the Committee of the Regions and it
is what they will be in the green zone
or what they will be in the
blouse waves for the diplomat is hungry
I need  a bit of some
clarification to know how it
works and from below on site
thank you very much to the deals for this
question but you understand that this
is a question that should be addressed
to the organizers of the conference not to
the commission  we can
possibly provide details on
the delegation of the
european commission to the cop16 in glasgow but
we cannot give you
organizational details on the access that
other delegations will have to the different
areas of the conference so I
t  invite you to contact the
British authorities who will certainly be
able to answer questions
since we are on this subject are there
any other questions
on coop 26 or the climate policy  matics of
the european commission today
please only keep your hand raised in
the interaction if it's on this
powerful topic that would take effect comfortably in 10
av mosey mo cache and
not 5
[Music]
this
promising tool is like this and moselle
indicator is
understood the
signs left to calls and
private high schools and even species of quota
ok
become
about
twenty craftsmen tidiane
sy who
ping next year ghassan of worship is
considerable
what we do not take from the hills
loads is exactly because we are going
to
man turn off by heart movie extract
explore
[Music]
existing moratorium stacks part of the
rare items places as
well as clues
continue death from spider 36 dastardly
energetic at tr
min stage lighthouse couple  mourinho blind side
[Music]
very close to 1 international monetary strategy
king on the sly hyndman
fraud to
said ignore
if we all deuch you so we
came back to do  with you have
no
name soul mate vieira who has
[Music]
not
yet
known as a
denial photo nathalie baye stop and go 17
watts unilateral in coordination with
el baida authorities in the stability
and acceptable at the level of the various
police car operations action
stock correction is main
clues can retain their will
to sensitive virus on your april dann
in 10 parts
eu colors ni motor action
fqu author of confrontation in
tengchong x264 crisis and counter and dunk
du all too much
of
mana and to  be done
in
situ exchanges which led to witch
mountain chance confrontation archos by
and coordination of interactions
efforts
concludes domestic fuel
important of our wins a cobbler
or a university you
have like hunting essence of fame
gone to another coordinator
caste innopole inaf a
particular date  context of crisis in
situation an offer to the second north of
delhi the bigger bang a context
of  are six notes 10 cannot be reduced of
reaction cannot be reduced to the
operations and
symptomatic every now and then in
say practice their have said nothing said this
party as often weeds belang and rich
ricci spite of the context of god is
going green serbia in kosovo
everything  fan find a way of life
and
death from context
of
peter phillips
to
fix you
think
partinico
radio
context contest we keep it
notification
of 10 specific batches
france is another he said
coordination
a
context
where this context notre
dame sall
d'afrique noire d  africa
receiving sessions
to
continue in this
summit
ue
peter six years in prison
specifically in furnace philippe
[Music]
the best
that at the match all scenery
[Music]
security 5 million practitioners of the
match at the dac hyp qt at this book exchange
510 k singh libya
our efforts anne a
tout
vu
[Music]
and
opposition positions that seem member
states of you need i  s very clear and very
strong attachment to sovereignties a
territory integrity
goris loud and clear do
n't know what it will take
three foam cabins we indicated
but it's both of us no
closure
[Music]
sipa
politics in
front of claudine
the
question
yes but i want to go to iran i
don't want to go to the balkans so
in this case we will first move on to
mathieu who had raised his hand before you
so mathieu you have a question on
international relations
and  christian will come back after
hello it's to go to venezuela
so yes al bazi I had asked for a
reaction
[Music]
especially after the f ti paper according to
which the high representative had
ignored the recommendations of the experts
dispatched on site to make his
decision  to organize a feint to
deploy a workplace mission
his electoral i go out what were the
political considerations
that outweigh the recom  mandates
explain the experts and
for sending this mission thank
you thank you 1 it is not true that their
representatives ignored the advice of a
drink the experts
the situation and as I will try
explained we sent an
exploratory exploitation mission  mission in
less than juliette a venezuela to
check if there are conditions will be able to
send an
own electoral observation
mission the mission explains exploitation of the
explorers and michel exploration the
exploration mission has submitted we do not
postpone to the end of this  mission
it was in the summer since the summer until
the decision on the electoral observation mission
in october the child of
september there was a lot of
development have venezuela the situation
in venezuela is very fluid there is a
lot of  development so I can
thus t4 1 action of 4 development
which contributed to one to make this
decision so there the report the report
of the exploitation mission it was  t
only in one aspect that we considered
in this decision in the meantime we
restarted the negotiations between the
regime and the opposition in mexico there
was a decision of parties of
political parties of the opposition for
the participation in the elections in
november local and regional elections
and also there was a cancellation of
restriction for the
for the opposition candidate and also we
signed a damn an agreement we say orang
administrative leads with the venez
elan authorities to guarantee to us th
t our mission of  election observation
can exercise effect
observation according to our methodology
those in other criteria so these are
the four factors that also
contributed in the in the decision is
the decision was also motivated by the
fidh stutterer and by the reactions
we received from the party  civil societies
in venezuela who asked for a
rookie who agreed with us with
another on a mission to
electoral observation is also in our contact
with the partners in the political field,
we also
clearly expressed with his missions, so
it was a very complex process, it is
true that the representative ignored the
advice given by the experts, but  the
report was only one aspect therefore
the report the development in
venezuela the discussions with the
modern style with the partners also with
the member countries with the
european parliament I would like to underline that the
figure at the buzzer the head of this
electoral observation mission is a
member of the european parliament very
experienced and in the field
of election observation so all
this aspect that we were considered the
decision was taken to send the mission
it is always possible if there are not
specific conditions too
something changes we can withdraw the
mission but we see the mission
not as a european contribution
to find the ground  ution of the
political crisis in venezuela because the
elections are of some
factors or aspects that can contribute to the
solution
thank you very much
we continue our world tour
today and so we are
now going to iran christian we are
flying to you  for your question
about iran
yes thank you
enrique mora left for tehran from a
tweet and saying he had met
his alter ego
my first question i would like to know
how long will he stay
in iran my second question  relates to
the resumption of the negotiations which had
been initiated in vienna and which were
suspended
during the talks of mr borel in
new york with the iranians the
iranians said in the coming weeks well
i wanted to know the next few
weeks it's the next few weeks
these next months these next years
because for the moment we
still do not see anything and therefore the stupid question
is what is a deadline which is
fixed for the  the resumption
of the vienna negotiations and i am asking this because in
fact the americans banged on the
table they used a tone which is
quite harsh which meets the concerns
of israel but israel is not party to
the agreement but it  there is a very
heavy threat which is that of a
military intervention and here we are entering an
area which is very very dangerous so
I remain to see how you
analyze the position taken by
the byden administration on
this file  'there is an emergency I think a
brick and moral said do you
have a deadline is still specious this
mexico agreement it's still five
questions all at once
you have to when it can so if we take
advantage of it  we will no longer be able to
find our way around so we will try to
answer your questions but please
try
to ask one or even two questions at
most in your interventions otherwise it
becomes absolutely impossible for us
to answer your requests correctly.  es
and
political directors of an
external action service travel a lot,
it's not just boillat tehran, he
sees russia and the united states, other
countries because it's a roll of
foreign action service officials,
travel and have  a line
hold with the partners in the
context of the negotiations in the name of the
efforts to restart the
negotiations in vienna i can only
say that it makes a crazy europe in has
all the assets the meetings that it
would have present as the coordinator of
the nuclear court  had in new york with
the partners and yes the Iranians
told us we will start again
soon
here we can we can discuss if these
soon it will tell you tomorrow at
lalano next year but I think
there is a dynamic between us  are the
coordinator the high representative is the
coordinator of a nuclear intercourse
so he will call the
meeting if all the parties of the rope
are ready to see the  meeting so
we expect the iranian response
or yes you can see there
visit from an erik morales now
as common factors that one must
stress the urgency to renew
start the discussion again today the
high representative
in bosnia tons she goes he goes  speaking
with secretary of state blinken also
on the nuclear agreements so we will
see the result of these discussions a
little later today or tomorrow of
course as I say we are his computer
so we are going to have we are going to
launch a new ray nor  years when
all the partners are ready these
meetings are full we hope and
we underline the urgency of having these
two meetings
very very quickly very soon
ok I'm going to take one last question
on international relations business
I'm sorry but that's
been  already more than half an hour that we
are on these subjects there are other
questions which await so I pass to
salam with a question s  ur lebanon
of course will leave its disposal
after the 2010 appointment on
all subjects salam yoko ono in the banana
absolutely and caused the fury
[Music]
of the sabbath obstruction 30 this tract
investigations laborda
is
[Music]
exact as long  that
the two confrontations of the data if
maureen of the data of six models nine
runners pippa which is
10h protests fourcade between
the dragons formulate
expeditiously
instigation to proceed fast
and interior
of lebanese multiples
of a
need to 1% chance on tennis possible
if  the member state grid corp ministers
we asked the accents board ivtb of the
lebanese internal situation at the
football match or mini troop of ariane daguin
vineet with powders
diary of bits of 800
political francs to economic actors
and lebanese spie by pai for it
happened to  highlight
forclose
4l we come back from coaching by philippe
soler on le finance sing off wiebels
fossils and bienne coscoll 5th  t peter
and a
new
york
in this context
project
blue
mission to study and
Libyan force to tackle
minute on a shot and a charge of
internet users
a coincidence because all
[Music]
beast
of
[Music]
visitors like that but
[Music  ]
also by
a loss of
people
exist do you have any guarantee
Libyan bybee of our people anthem with has
made no blunders like fayoum 100
but I dare everything but to be hot from
kibera b
in this capacity
there are some left and  hot chocolate wilate
specifically all of the assignments
david
yes thank you eric at the
beginning of July there was
an accident with a libyan coast guard boat
that
they
had who attacked they
used weapons against forced
migrant boats the boat and  was part
if I remember correctly of the boats
that the European states where the
European Union had given
hockey one coast guard I wanted to
know how much and the investigation that you had
has  nnounced at the time and what are the
guarantees that the next
boats that you have given
will not be used in the same
way thank you
that at the death in the angle it is more a
question for ana but a question for
peter so
you if  you want you can deny or you want to
come back
komm from acs in training
there was
another problem of cities you couldn't
know
thank you david we answered this
question last week
already a few days after the incident
it was in the head a few days
after
the authorities responsible for this
boat said and condemned the incident
and we took the necessary actions
against the commander 17 17 boats
so above all that I can remember
thank you here I close the  chapter on
libya and I return to mines d'alès
conference
board
of invitation
d
be 2010par france we must not split hairs
we have situation on board this same
time of the
[Music]
reflection
yes to a contact clause is
right let's move we have here we say wendy
and 4 faults when
he bills at random i pad wii too and
what i am in cash at and fouras
d'albert
hidden d'albert standards
pretending to be a d'albert is what the
polish authorities have already accepted
the presence of the
commission's delegation on
the border because there was first
a delegation which passed through warsaw
the commissioner announced the  visit also
on the border is there already
a date is that they have already accepted
thank you thank you cash for the moment we
do not have confirmation of
this visit yet we continue to
work in dialogue with the
authorities  on this
visit to the border we continue to
insist that this visit is
extremely important for the
commission for the moment we do
not have confirmation from the
Polish authorities that this visit
can take place at the border as
this  the was announced
at the kef stables match
here our queen sfo fans from albert be
go back from tomaso
des
seals
thomazo
yes hello yes hello thanks for
giving me the look and i have two
questions for stefan i think one
c  is on the copy of the first get
drunk vaccines of the curve ac because
in the German company to a
press release that it will leave
abandoned the voxels the first version
of the vaccine but that they are
working on its second version  more
promises tries with
glaxosmithkline is what the commission
could
assess signed a contract with curve ax
on vaccines more bidder but tries and
the second is on the drug
brands it's my opinion which is a
drug against
accovia like and  this
so tommaso so don't fly with
tacconi who didn't hear the second
part of issue are generally
connection merck
should small to questions about merck
ok I have I excluded the video because I
think q  ue that there is a problem of the
accounts of the
connectivities on merkel
and that the day before against empty lacko
I read that the commission could
there is a contract fruit of one of the two
sign a contract with merck and is it
whether that is true or false thank you game
stéphane thank you thank you very much let's start
first I may be able to answer your
question as concerning known worse
mounir with respect to the company merck
you know that contracts of a
joint venture
always  possible it is necessary for this
that there is an interest on the part of the
member states of the appa of the commission and if this
is the case contracts can be
concluded I cannot tell you more
with regard to this product my  the worst to
turn from merck but in theory i can
point out that it is up to the member states
with the commission to here or not there is
a need to conclude a contract under the
grouped purchases excuses elections to
the grouped purchase therefore the contract of
group purchase pending consideration of
a whole series of elements  ments such as the
epidemiological situation the needs that the
member states could have and it is
with regard to the curve ac yes we
have become aware of the fact that the
company has withdrawn its request for the
devaluation of its vaccine candidate which
is currently being
analyzed i  would say
by emma we are
obviously reviewing the situation and the contract
we have we have a contract with the
company
we are reviewing we are analyzing the contract
to see what the consequences are
but I can't comment yet
on
any next steps that  'we could
take the commission here thank
you thank you are there any other questions on the
health situation for
stéphane today
that is not the case thank you stéphane
part
of the
two present formations
of the sydney police
cedes
ribéry only have  a
desire is we need opinion
we say
lorenzo di
lorenzo tignes or unfit probably is
there where
you can hear me rivasi
ok yes that's for sure it's ok the question  i
wanted to understand better because
yesterday commissioner
simpson
rightly said that when we had spoken to
the commission which has just lived
now and about the question of judgment
beyond the constitutional tribunal for
polish people and i wanted to understand well
because she in fact you  just said
that the commission has not yesterday two
of the preliminary conclusions of
the analysis is who makes them
final conclusions but if I
understood correctly the final conclusion will
be after the European concert, that is to
say after  we heard the member states
is what i like i misunderstood
because the thing that surprises me a little is
that the commission as guardian
of the treaties should have a
very clear position it is very clear  on seven
existential challenges to the
pensioners union which was signed and ratified
when poland and which now
is denying
its existence and and in fact it
looks like the commission is waiting to
know what th  st that member states are
going to say she's that she's used to the
break if member states have
support her
if there will be some kind of green fairy is in
love you are waiting for you makes you
green member states to act  against
poland which launched this existential challenge
to the european union
lorenzo i believe that you pay little attention
to the need for an institution
like the european commission which is the
guardian
of the basic treaties and
these actions on a legal analysis
which is
entirely  solid that is completely
supported by the effect is therefore up to
you to interpret the time we
take to do this analysis
according to other criteria but I
can assure you here that the only thing
that says 'work  of the commission
and the rhythm of the analysis of this judgment
it is the need to carry out an analysis
which is
indisputable, but
as you know this judgment has
just been officially published by the
Polish authorities, I
believe  other than in fact the reasonings
I'm not quite sure we will have
to check but in any case the
latest news I had was
that the judgment pronounced had been
published but it was still necessary to publish them
so awaits the  reasoning and having this
judgment once again to check but
whatever it is on such a
serious and complex matter you
understand that even if we
take this matter extremely
seriously that we want to move forward as
quickly as possible without a  without wasting
time, as I had the opportunity to
say, that does not mean that we are
going to release our analysis according
to such and such a deadline that may arise,
it is a question of ensuring that
we have an analysis that  is
absolutely indisputable from a legal point of
view and that is the only thing
that says about our action
are there any other questions on this subject
that is not the case I will take one
last question is
my p  assion he
's hungry
the
life commission
[Music]